is everything okay the new Star Wars is
a surprise hit I think we have expected
that for the most we need to start
strategizing yeah the enthusiasms I have
a million ideas and I feel like God want
me to be writing this down 10 movies a
year okay that's our minimum right I
think people might get a little tired of
all Obi-Wan Kenobi got some movies the
prequels they're good now so let's do
like prequel related things it's a great
idea let's bring in some fresh voices
um is ingmar Bergman still around he's
he's dead he died ah damn okay everyone
gets a Trilogy I feel like who who made
uh soprano let me see if he's available
Innovation Innovation I will never die
say it say it with me me just say it I
will never die no I will never forget it
sure I'm on the phone with Kevin feige
he's wondering about his Trilogy I'm not
I'm not here we'll talk to you later
people got tired of Star Wars really
fast no I'm just your assistant but I am
getting a lot of calls and texts from
people saying you gave them a Trilogy I
can't talk to them got to do something
to fix this no more star maybe like no
more Star Wars ever again Ryan Johnson
got my personal number somehow he keeps
asking me when we're gonna do his Star
Wars things so TV he is the new movies
anyways right let's just keep doing TV
just like mediocre sometimes good TV and
then people will like us again I don't
think David Lynch was that interested in
the Mace Windu series maybe if we hired
Todd field he did talk if we got some of
that tar energy in here yeah yes what
stop letting me talk